I've gotten kids real questions to ask
you guys about the movie so read Jessie
who's five wants to know pig where did
you learn to dance and did you get in
trouble for knocking over all those
oranges
I learned well my pig character learns
from another Pig named Gunther and I'm
fun that sounds like that and I picked
up all the oranges at the end because
it's not nice to leave a mess Jesse
wants to know is your theater downtown
and is it just for animals or canoe
bands go there too humans can go there
but I don't know I didn't see any I
don't think there's any humans in this
world but yes come one come all we would
we would accept the the human animal as
well ran who's six would like to know
why does the Koala sleep in a drawer
because he doesn't have a eucalyptus
tree Jessie who's five says you're tall
did you eat lots of vegetables to get
tall I'm not that tall Jonny the
gorillas pretty tall yeah
Johnny the gorilla is taught and that's
because he eats all of his greens and he
goes to bed exactly when his dad tells
him to addy who's six nice to know why
did the elephant scream in the
microphone if she didn't want to sing
this is amazing um gosh I you know what
Meena was just really nervous and that's
the only sound that would come out of
her she didn't she couldn't sing she
couldn't get the notes out so that was
the only note that would come out is the
screen if you could sum up your
character in one dance move just in your
chair I made you join that be right
we're dabbing we're dabbing Amina dance
Mamina dance just so shy that mean Amina
oh yeah
[Music]
you